what is this social window thing that
we've been hearing about the social
window is a period of time and if I were
to just put in a timeline or let me
speak from a filmmaker perspective it's
the time when your movies out of the
festivals or just after festivals right
when the time when people are starting
to hear about your movie where are you
getting these emails and the emails are
like what is this movie going to be
available I can't wait to see it two
things are happening here one is this is
a period of time when people are most
interested in your movie and secondly
those are your early adopters the people
that are most eager to get a piece of
your movie and go out and tell their
friends about it and the normal response
to these questions are I'm talking to
the distributor just wait we've got to
find out about these things so what
you're doing is you're telling your most
enthusiastic fan that they have to wait
for something so what we aim to do a
chill is get you at least in a situation
where you can take advantage of the
social window this time when people are
most enthusiastic about your movie you
can at least get it up on chill in a
pre-order environment which means it
won't be available to them but they can
pre-order this thing that they want to
see so why is that important these
people that are your early adopters in
the social window want more than just
the movie so when they come to chill and
they check out your movie what they're
going to find is they can get something
that's far and above just the movie so
in the case of like a movie let's say we
have a movie that has a deal with like a
famous rock band you know you might have
a you might have a bundle on their
merchandise bundle it could be an
experience it could be a digital
download it could be a physical product
but let's say you have an experienced
bundle and let's say it's a real famous
musician and for ten thousand dollars
you can have dinner with this musician
well suddenly because im an enthusiastic
fan and i happen to have an extra ten
thousand dollars suddenly i think that's
really valuable so i buy it this would
not be available if you were to just put
your movie on all platforms at once that
person that same enthusiastic fan would
buy it anywhere else they would they
would just buy them they might buy it on
Amazon because they want to see the
movie but what you've lost out as as a
filmmaker what you've lost out on is the
ability to provide something
above just the movie at a time when
people are most enthusiastic about it
when do you think that social window
fades because what if someone's taking a
really long time with the film it's
almost there hey guys updates we're
almost there almost there what do you
think it starts to wane yeah that's the
thing it does start to wane I mean that
same person that emails you very early
on in the social window saying I can't
wait to see your movie i'm so pumped
about it you know six months to a year
later when you realize that half the
distribution deals you know that people
offered you didn't turn out to be the
deal you expected you reach out to him
and you're like hey my movies finally
available and named the marketplace
right it's finally available by now and
that guy's suddenly like oh yeah that
was that movie I used to be excited
about you know what I mean it's just it
fades and it's different for each movie
but i would say 180 days is pretty long
you know to make somebody wait right so
but let's say you put it in a pre-order
situation while you're still in the
social window now you can monitor in
terms of sales you can watch the sales
go up there going to hit a peak they're
going to plateau for a bit and as they
start to drop down that's a time where
we say okay time to take it out on the
other marketplaces so it's not the chill
is the only destination for your movie
we never say that but we do say then
should be the first destination
you